Daniel: Hello and welcome, everyone.
It's June 3, 2023.
We're in the first discussion section for
Physics as information processing course
with Chris Fields.
So welcome to all who are here on and off
camera.
Really exciting to see so many people
joining for this participatory discussion
section.
So in this first interval, we're going to
go to anyone who raises their hand, and
it would be awesome to hear from everyone
who would like to share what excites them
about what they heard in the first
lecture.
How has their background and journey led
to them joining?
What are they hoping to learn and do in
this course?
So firsthand we'll get to go, maybe.
Ander you can actually start first, just
speaking as a normal participant.
And then meanwhile, anyone is welcome to
raise their hands.
Ander: That sounds good.
So I am a mathematician by training, but
I've always been interested in the more
physics side of things.
And in particular, I followed Chris's
work pretty closely since probably 2019.
I'm just very interested in the whole
ontology of quantum measurement, what it
means.
I feel like very often when it's taught
in physics classes, it's hand waved away.
.
And even though I myself subscribe to the
philosophy of shut up and compute,
sometimes not everything you need to do a
little bit of philosophy, maybe, and this
may be one of the things where you need
to do it and you need to address it from
first principles.
Right?
And I think Chris is doing that.
So I'm just here to learn more.
And yeah, that's basically it.
Daniel: Awesome.
I'll just go from the top left because I'
'm not necessarily watching, like, what
order, but Ross first.
Ross: Hi.
I'm interested in the kind of overlap
between cognitive science and physics and
seeing if there are any panpsychist
implications of the observation that
physical processes seem to follow the
same kind of principle that we see
applied to brains and cognitive systems.
Daniel: Awesome.
Thank you. Avel?
Avel: Hi.
I'm Avel Guenin-Carlut.
I have mixed backgrounds, mostly physics
and cognitive science.
Right now, I could be qualified as a
philosopher of physics and cognitive
science.
And I'm interested in basically
formalizing participatorialism, the idea
that observer participates in creating
reality.
I did some work in formalizing that in
the case of social norms and things like
language.
And I met a block based on my lack of
knowledge of quantum physics and the
mathematical tools that I used for that.
So I'm here in a course to get those
formal skills.
Daniel: Awesome.
Thank you,
Avel. Bleu?
Bleu: I think Alexey was first.
Daniel: Okay, Alexey, go for it.
Bleu: Sorry.
Ali: Hi, I'm Alexey.
I'm a clinical psychologist in Maryland.
In the States.
I work with patients, do psychotherapy
mostly.
My interest came through Mark Solms, who
is the creator and leader of
neuropsychoanalysis, and he has been
collaborating with Friston on “the hard
problem of consciousness,” and he's now
working on AI with emotions.
I blame him.
I say it with respect and love that for
introducing mathematics into our field,
which was mostly devoid of mathematics.
And people started looking at these
partial differential equations and Markov
blankets.
So I wrote a paper about a possible
extension of their model to include chaos
theory and I just want to understand
deeper concepts involved.
I have some understanding of them, but
perhaps not enough.
And I'm enjoying this course a great deal.
.
I think Chris, among other things, is a
fantastic teacher and he is able to
express things very clearly and I have
awe – I have goosebumps.
So I'm very grateful to everybody and
thank you so much.
Daniel: Cool.
Bleu. Then, Francesco.
Bleu: Hi, everyone.
I'm Bleu Knight.
I'm with the Active Inference Institute.
So I've been tracking this work of Chris'
's connecting quantum information and
Active Inference for, I don't know, a
couple of years now.
Through that thread, I'm super interested
actually in the aspect of spacetime
arising from communication.
I think that that's like fascinating to
dive into and how it connects to the
Buddhist and maybe more Eastern religion
concept of dependent arising, like how
the interdependence of all things leads
to their existence.
From that aspect.
I think that's what I'm most interested
in exploring my background is
neuroscience, but I've also been studying
practicing Buddhism for like 25 years.
So yeah, that's it.
Thanks.
Daniel: Awesome.
Francesco. Then, Corby.
Dean: Thanks,
Daniel. Ciao, everyone!
Super happy to be here.
I also have a mixed background because I
studied cognitive anthropology and
philosophy of science.
And currently a few months ago I started
a PhD in artificial intelligence in an
8th application in the educational field.
.
And yes, I'm actually super excited about
all the science based implications that
Chris Fields mentioned in the first
lecture.
The connection I have no background in
physics, but the connections between the
first principles, physics and free energy
principle and scientific cognition in
general is what is really getting me
excited in these days.
Daniel: Thank you.
Cool.
Corby. Then,
anyone else who raises their hand.
Corby: Yeah, great to be here.
My background is in quantum engineering.
I've always been motivated by figuring
out what the next big thing in computing
was.
In high school, Moore’s Law was sort of
coming to an end and it seemed like a
really big opportunity to figure out what
the next big computing architecture might
be.
So I did academic research in
neuromorphic computing, quantum computing
and quantum sensors.
And I felt like I was a little bit too
early for all of those things.
So I went into cloud and cloud gaming and
streaming AI services.
But I'm still extremely motivated to
figure out what the next big thing is.
And the Holographic principle
seems like a good foundation to explore
Ander: that.
Daniel: Awesome.
I'll raise my own hand then.
Anyone else is welcome to go.
So, I'm Daniel.
I'm a researcher at the institute and
have known ander for some years and
learned about all kinds of Stochastic
matrices and how the math and the quantum
were linked.
And we had talked and joked about
learning from Chris Fields for a long
time.
So when the opportunity arose to enact it
and extend it and open it, we were very
excited and also don't have much of a
formal background in physics outside of
working with Yaaka bin Ali on Live stream
49.
So it's just going to be a great time to
learn and see where it all goes.
Anyone else want to say hello in this
kind of opening section?
Okay, well, continuing forward, of course,
, please just feel free to raise your
hand anytime you'd like to jump into the
stack. Andre, for several minutes or
however you see,
could you reflect on Lecture One?
Where did Chris enter?
How did he proceed?
And where did the lecture take us?
Thank you.
Ander: Yeah.
Daniel: {Can you zoom in a little bit
more on the PDF?}
Ander:
Daniel:
Ander: Let's take a look at the slides
from last time.
So I think if we were to summarize this
whole lecture, basically what Chris was
trying to say is that there are many
hands coming from different directions,
pointing at the same thing, right?
Pointing at the fact that information
will have a central aspect in physics in
the future, but also possibly biology,
right?
So the earliest hints came from
statistical mechanics, if you wish, but
also quantum mechanics, right?
And here we need to make an important but
subtle distinction between what it is,
the uncertainty principle, right?
Because we think of that as the
informational part, right?
Like a limit on the resolution on
information and what is the observer
effect.
Just to make that distinction clear.
I think Chris is talking about the
observer effect.
The uncertainty principle is an artifact
of the wave nature of quantum mechanics,
right?
You can get it from properties of the
Fourier transform, cautious words,
inequality.
But at the end of the day, it's what I
was saying earlier, right?
What is the basic picture of measurement,
right?
And that's sort of what Crease with
Glazebrook and Marciana is trying to
address.
And the first two hints came from quantum
mechanics around 1900 and statistical
mechanics a few decades earlier.
Then there's more stuff, right?
Like, obviously physicists resisted to
inertia of hundreds of years of a totally
objective, observer independent universe,
but the hints continued to pile on some
stuff coming from math.
But perhaps the most interesting is,
again, how all those paradoxes from
statistical mechanics were made sense of
with Landauers proposal.
And then as physics got more fancy past
QFT and stuff, people started thinking
about quantum information more seriously.
.
So we had Bell Serum and all these
proposals by Deutsche and Wheeler and so
on.
And I should say that this is not a
fringe idea in physics.
The paradigm of it from qubit is very
much mainstream.
I mean, Google it.
A lot of physicists think about it.
I don't know how many of them talk about
it.
Openly, but it's been a widespread folk
intuition, so to speak, that information
will have this sort of central role.
And the last sort of hints pointing in
that direction of information having a
central law came on the one side from
high energy stuff.
And that's what the Holographic principle
is.
It originally arose in the context of
black hole thermodynamics, but then it
was extended to what's called the Ads CFT
correspondence.
And the very most recent stuff was
basically one side from high energy stuff.
.
Sorry, I can speak a little more loudly.
Daniel: It's all good.
Continue.
Honor.
Ander: Yeah, I thought there was a
question.
Daniel: Someone was just unmuted.
It's all good.
Ander: Okay.
Yeah.
So that's basically it, right?
There's hints from many directions, and
most recently the work of Friston and
Levin coming from biology, all pointing
in the same direction, right.
That we might have to make sense of some
sort of eventually scale free information
processing per data for what it means to
be an observer.
All of these things are pointing in that
direction.
And I think Chris's work is addressing
that head on.
Right.
As I said earlier, sometimes it's good to
do computations, but sometimes you need
to take a step back and think more
philosophically about what you're doing
and what the bigger picture is.
And then maybe after people talk a little
bit, we can warm up to the second lecture.
.
The other windows that I have open here,
some of them are the papers that are to
come.
Yeah.
Anyone?
Daniel: Please feel free to raise your
hand on this.
Alexey and then anyone else?
Ali: I had one thought about this thing
when you mentioned that there's various
perspectives on the same concept.
And I'm trying to be cautious.
On the one hand, I think, again, this
amazing clarity and precision with which
Chris expressed thoughts is fantastic and
enjoyable.
On the other hand, it requires
simplification and generalization.
And what I observe in my field is people
take a term like entropy and run with it.
.
And then they get very quickly from
thermodynamic entropy to Shannon to
whatever entropy.
And they talk about sort of and that's
not the case.
I mean, if we go back to Klausius and all
the others, there was a system of
postulates and axioms that must be
maintained.
And if you step outside of that so, like
us organisms, we're open systems.
We're not closed systems.
So we should not apply directly.
Second law thermodynamics and I deal a
little more with comogorphs and eye
entropy, which is not the same thing.
And I guess when we very quickly move
from sort of thermodynamics to
statistical mechanics with Boltzman to
all the way around and we assume it is
the same thing, I think we may need to be
careful because we are just ignoring the
differences in assumptions.
Shannon talked about telegraph.
He talked about a receiver getting a
message from a sender, right?
And Clausius talked about gas.
But I do think it's a balancing act and
there's no way to not have simplification
and generalization.
I just wanted to say somewhere, somehow
we need to kind of go back there and just
say entropy is not entropy is not entropy.
.
And all these things are kind of long
papers, right?
Ander: Yes.
Daniel: Yakub, then Ali, then anyone
else?
Ander: I just wanted to ask for, I guess
perhaps slightly longer comment from
Alexi on what you see as the fundamental
differences in different descriptions of
entropy and whether there is some general
concept that could be extracted from all
of them, such as level of information or
uncertainty about a particular system.
Even though these specific formulations
of entropy, they talk about, they were
derived from different specific systems
and they have different equations
describing them and they mean slightly
different things, do you think it would
be wrong to say that there is some
commonality between them?
Ali: Should I answer Daniel or yeah,
please.
I don't know, I just think we need to at
some point formalize it and be careful
with these generalizations.
For example, when we talk about Active
Inference and Kristen right.
When we say living organisms must
minimize I'm quoting Kristen, by the way,
these are not my thoughts.
The entropy of sensory states, right?
And then people take that idea sometimes
and generalize and they say that that's
what life is, minimization of entropy.
Right?
But if you actually look into human brain
and measure entropy, then it goes all
over the place, up, down and in between.
And so I don't think that's an accurate
description.
And the reason for that is where we
shifted away from the assumptions.
And again, so comagorfsini entropy talks
about the phase space and the divergence
of trajectories in phase space and sort
of the volume and face space, while when
you talk about this Briston's entropy of
sensory states, these are probability
distributions.
And Shannon talked about the uncertainty
of the receiver, about the message sent
by the sender.
So if you want to extract the same thing,
I suppose you can.
But it's important not to lose at least
the difference between what kind of
object are we applying to?
Are we looking at probability
distributions?
Are we looking at phase space?
Are we looking at ideal gas?
Where are we at?
And we're just not to say entropy is
entropy is entropy.
That's not the case.
It's just a formula, but depending on the
context, assumptions and things, it can
be very different.
Daniel: Thanks, Ali.
And Avel.
Ali: Yes.
In regard to Alex's comments, I just
wanted to mention the research of people
like Rudolph Hannel and Stefan Surger,
because for many years they've been
exploring this idea of different
conceptions of entropy and they've come
up with at least a dozen different
meanings for entropy.
And they've formulated it in a kind of
generalized framework, but at the same
time, they've also devised a way to
somehow classify them into equivalence
classes and to see whether one or more of
those conceptions of entropy can be
theoretically derived from some others or
they're totally distinct and different
conceptions of entropy.
So, yes, I agree that in some situations,
we need to be more specific about what
exactly we mean by entropy and
information.
I mean, based on the question or the
situation of interest.
Daniel: Thanks, Avil.
Avel: So, just to vote in the entropy
discussion, I want to emphasize that
entropy is PLNP.
So it's a function of probability
distribution, which is I think I'm not
sure what the term is in English, but it'
's a measure of how big something is in a
space.
And to get that, you have to define a
And in many case, it's pretty arbitrary
to decide what the space you're looking
at is.
For example, you talk I don't know if it
was Alexa, someone talked about entropy
of fMRI.
Well, those are aggregate measurements of
general activity.
This is not the space of all possible
configuration.
And even if I add something like the
space of all, let's say, functional
configuration, the state in neuron that
reflect activity, this would be another
thing than the space of atomic
configuration, where the specific atom
are.
You don't have a warranty that when you
define entropy, you define it on a
meaningful space that's not given.
I kind of think there is one entropy and
that's it, and it's an info construct.
But also we have to if we agree to that,
then it entails that we have to find it.
It's not just given out there in the data.
.
Daniel: Well, certainly being precise in
the formalism and in natural language for
what we mean by information and entropy
and all these terms is pretty important.
I mean, the course we're in is physics as
information processing.
But without an understanding of how
information is being meant here or what
measurements and transformations were
performing what informational operations,
then it is a non sequitur.
So how do we go about clarifying or
understanding what kinds of theoretical
results in a given domain or, like, what
is shown on the timeline here might apply
to some other area?
Just one thought.
Anyone else can raise their hand with a
thought or a question.
Otherwise honor, you can maybe flip over
to select a few of the submitted
questions.
Cool.
Could you zoom in with control plus a
fair amount?
Thanks.
So, everyone, we really appreciate the
submitted questions.
We've been able to get 13 answered by
Chris so far.
And as with the transcripts of the
discussions and lectures, the questions
and answers are going to be part of what
is published by the Octemf Journal.
So we really encourage basic questions,
advanced questions, just there's no
question that doesn't make sense to
submit.
So, Andre, maybe just pick one question
that you think is interesting to begin
with and summarize Chris's response, and
then everyone else is welcome to kind of
add some other thoughts on this.
Ander: So, I'm going to scroll up and
down just to sort of sample.
Let me start with the first two.
Can you hear me?
Well?
Yes, since perhaps I think you submitted
this as a trial, right?
Is that right?
Yeah.
So what is information?
What is time?
Here is Chris's response.
I guess everyone has a chance to look at
it.
Now, if I am to summarize this, the one
thing I've heard that personally, the one
I like the most, answer, at least as an
Adash, to summarize it, is that
information are differences that make a
difference.
This I might have heard from Chris, I
might have heard from someone else.
I don't remember.
But that's one thing.
Now, onto the question of what is time,
and I guess this also addresses Alex's
question of what is entropy.
Daniel: I'll.
Ander: Make a bigger point now.
What is time?
This is partially addressed, and I guess
the main thing I'll be doing here is
rather than look back, look forward into
what's to come in the course, in
particular, I'm thinking about these two
papers and in particular, and I finally
chat with Chris about this this picture
over here.
Okay.
Daniel: More?
Ander: Yeah.
I'll get back to it in a bit.
But basically, this sort of, like, kills
two birds with a stone, right?
This picture, and especially the text
around it, and the title of this paper is
The Physical Meaning of the Holographic
Principle.
Okay.
You guys can see here archive 22, ten,
blah, blah, blah.
Anyways, this addresses the notion of
time and entropy, because the claim that'
's made in this paper is that these are
local observer relative definitions, and
we can look into more detail around it.
But basically, the coordinate ta time is
an entropic measure, so it is non
decreasing, and it goes up with the
observer measuring entropy in the system.
.
Because of the symmetry of the definition.
The second law applies to both.
So both observer and environment see
entropy increasing in their environment
and vice versa.
Anyways, from this picture, one gets that
you have this internal circle time QRF.
So this just is a necessary artifact of
recording information into a memory that'
's the claim made in the paper, and that
essentially induces the passage of time,
at least from the perspective of the
observer.
It also, I think, Alexey was talking
about, which I totally understand and
agree that there's different notions of
entropy.
Now, I suppose I would be the one to like
definitions and so on, but I but I do
think it's it's it's good to to have a
certain amount of flexibility.
So I see it the same as energy, right?
Like, there are different kinds of energy.
.
You know, there's energy mass
equivalences.
And, you know, if you push it into
supersymmetry, you can think of it as
equivalent to force also.
But I do think there is some value in
being sloppy or intuitive about the
notion.
So the fact that entropy yes, there are
different definitions.
I don't see it quite as a problem one can
explore here.
Around this page, there is a definition
of local entropic time.
One can think of it as face pace, or one
can think of it as coding theory,
alashanum.
But it is at the end of the day, I do
think it is true that both of them are
hinting at the same direction.
Just like you may have different kinds of
energy, but they're not unrelated
concepts.
Yeah.
I hope one day we get very precise
definitions out of everything, but for
now, I think it's good to speculate.
Okay.
Yeah.
Daniel: Corby and then anyone else on
this?
Corby: Yeah, quick question.
So I haven't read that specific paper,
but is there any work on the frequency or
the rate at which one could read and
write information on the boundary?
Ander: Yes, well, I can't think of the
paper exactly, but this is lower bounded.
.
I think Chris talked about it, if not in
the last lecture.
I think I've seen a talk of him on
YouTube.
It's lower bounded by the uncertainty
principle.
Right.
For instance, Planck's constant is in
units of action, which is energy times
time.
Right.
So Landauer's principle says you need a
certain amount of energy to erase
information and you have time.
Right.
And then you have an energy time and
certain principle putting those things
together, you have a minimum amount of
action, which is literally the minimum.
The action is measuring what I said
earlier.
Right.
Like differences that make a difference,
the minimum difference that you can make.
.
So the minimum difference to erase a bit
or rewrite it on the boundary, so to
speak.
Right.
So, yeah, that would be given by the
uncertain relation, energy times time.
I don't know exactly what the figure is,
but it's obviously very small compared to
everyday life.
Corby: Got it.
And is there work on the upper bound?
Like, for example, would it be the number
of degrees of freedom on the boundary?
Ander: No, I don't think it's bounded
from above.
But obviously then we do want to bond it
from above for technological reasons, if
you wish.
But I think that is an engineering
problem, not one of physics.
Daniel: Andre, a few questions on this
figure.
What are Y and E?
The blue oval, as Chris has pointed out,
is going to consistently be the screen,
the blanket.
And so we often associate that with at
least some blankets.
Include these information gathering and
utilizing systems.
So what is happening internal to the
agent here?
What kind of computation is happening?
And is this something that is actually
proposed to be occurring?
Or is this a schematic or a map of how we
could think about something occurring?
Ander: I think this question is going to
be better addressed by Chris himself,
probably in the next lecture.
For now, what I can say is I can
reiterate what I was trying to say
earlier, which is that what this
addresses and this basic measurement
picture, so to speak, is the observer
effect, right?
Like this notion that you cannot observe
something without disturbing the
environment.
So if you then try to make sense of this
by constraining from first principles,
land hours, principle and so on, basic
requirements on information processing
from the point of view of energy, then
you get that this boundary is constrained
in some ways, right?
This Y is what's called the memory sector,
, meaning that you don't just act on the
immediate information that you perceive.
You may also act on stuff that's stored
that you have perceived before then sure,
e, the red part is what you're perceiving
right now, the environment.
But actually I don't know if I have it in
here, but this is further broken up into
other parts.
So not schematically here, let me try to
find it over here.
Now, I don't know, actually, bear with me
for a second.
I think you might be here.
That's the same picture anyways.
I don't want to waste time by trying to
find it, but back to the original picture
sure.
What you're measuring, and again, Chris
will talk about this in more detail, but
from first principle assumptions, they
deduce that you're going to have to
deploy your finite resources for
gathering information in clever ways on
the boundary, right?
So you're going to have to deploy some
resources for memory, some resources as a
heat sink, right?
So you're going to be processing
information, you're going to be dumping
so called low quality stuff into the
environment, you're going to be dumping
heat and then other than the memory, you'
're going to be focusing on what's going
on right now in this environment.
And what I wanted to say is that it can
be further broken up into what's called
pointer and reference sectors.
So you can imagine this e sector here has
to be broken into further sectors because
then there is the other first principle
notion.
Okay?
So what does it mean to observe
something?
The differences that make a difference,
right?
So there is only information with context,
, right?
There is no information per se.
It's all semantics, right?
So you only observe things in context.
So some things are going to have to stay
the same, namely reference states here,
and some things are going to bear,
right?
So you can think of this as the gauge in
your car, right?
Obviously the circle stays the same and
that's your context, so to speak, with
the numbers in it.
They never go away, they stay the same.
But as you speed up or down, the gauge is
going to change.
And that's how you know only in that
context you can tell your own speed when
you're driving a car, right?
So anyways, this is just a teaser for
things to come.
We can go back to more questions.
Daniel, what do you think?
I'll pick maybe two or three more over
here.
Yeah.
Daniel: Pick another question, or anyone
raising their hand, or if anyone in the
live chat wants to write something, I'll
read it.
How about the WIC rotation?
Could you summarize what the WIC rotation
is and then state this question about
it?
Ander: That's a great question.
I wish I knew the answer better.
But formally speaking, the Wick rotation
is just so Chris said, you take a
quantity multiply by I square root of
negative one.
That amounts to a 90 degree rotation in a
complex plane.
Fine.
Now, that appears to be a trick.
And what it does effectively is take you
from quantum mechanics to statistical
mechanics, roughly speaking.
Now, why it works, I have no clue.
I don't know the answer myself.
But now when things appear to be a trick
and they get you something, maybe there's
more to it than what's apparent at first,
but I myself don't know the answer.
It's a very good question, but I do think
it may have to do with the fact that on
the one hand, quantum and statistical
mechanics both are talking about
constraints on information processing,
maybe from different perspectives.
But again, that's just speculation on my
end, so it's maybe a way of relating the
two.
Daniel: Could we just review just read
Chris's full answer to this.
Read the question, and then Chris's full
answer.
Ander: Does the weak rotation to ask that
matter energy somehow exists 90 degrees
perpendicular to a three dimensional
space?
Daniel: And then I'll just read Chris's
answer.
Then anyone?
Please raise your hand if you want to add
something more on this.
He wrote, in a sense, yes, time is
perpendicular to our three dimensions of
space, matter, and energy.
We ourselves exist in time.
Wick is pointing to the intimate
relationship between how we measure time
and how we determine or judge that
something maintains its identity through
time.
I e.
Stays the same thing through time.
To tell time by a clock, I have to be
sure I'm looking at the same clock set
the same way, et cetera.
We'll get to this in July and August.
Could you connect this, Andrew, to some
of the semantic information flows
discussed in Live stream 17 or any of the
other cone co cone diagrams from the
papers that you showed earlier?
Ander: Sure.
Again, I have to preface it by saying
that I am working on understanding it
myself, but just from small email
exchange that I had with Chris ant waste
in this paper, one can sort of see that
it's related to the picture I was showing
earlier, namely this one.
Right.
But let's scroll down a little bit to
page to page 23 24.
Here they talk out with rotation again.
So I think it has it has to do with, at
least from what I heard from crazy email,
has to do with this notion of local time,
the definition of local time in this
observation picture, and the fact that
you rotate 90.
Degrees twice, you get the opposite sign,
basically, right?
So the local time, effectively, that's
going to ensure that the picture is
symmetric and that the flow is going to
be opposite in the direction towards the
observer and towards the environment.
Daniel: Okay, Alexey, then.
Anyone else raising their hands?
Ali: I am struggling to understand and
part of my difficulty bear with me for
being so kind of but I remember Sean
Carroll's lecture on time in different
versions of physics, and it took a whole
hour.
So are we talking Newtonian time, which
is universally the same?
Are we talking relative time
philosophically?
Are we talking about people who believe
that only present here and now is real,
while future and past do not exist?
So when we say time is perpendicular too,
my sense is that just like Chris
mentioned in the lecture, we're
reinventing the time.
We're creating a new definition by
calling it the same word we're all
familiar with.
And that creates some dissonance where I
just think that maybe we need to kind of
say that this is something new.
And if it's not something new, then which
version of the time are we talking
about?
Einsteinian, Newtonian or whatever?
It's a simple question before we say it's
perpendicular, do people agree that
future is real or not?
Daniel: I'll give it all on this, Alexey.
.
Again, speculation neither here nor then.
If we take Chris seriously, that
communication is an ontological primary
and that rather than putting
communications protocols in some sort of
time newtonian time, Einsteinian time,
these are these different time concepts,
these different scaffolds that then
communication gets inscribed within or
stretched within.
But if we start with a topological
understanding of communication rather
than a geometric understanding of
spacetime so the topology of the blanket
and the observer in their sensorium, then
different kinds of cognitive agents,
ranging from what we would call nonliving
to what we could call living.
They depending on their cognitive
sophistication are able to create or
project different time concepts.
Time concepts that are not useful will
lead to their own material dissolution,
the failure to maintain that kind of
cognitive sophistication, which requires
not just information gathering and
utilization, but also energy gathering
and utilization.
And so when you have multiple agents who
are whether you conceptualize them as
within a message passing relationship and
having no surprise on the clock on the
wall, then they're like in a local time
synchrony.
But the primary case is one entity
engaging with its sensorium and itself
modeling time in terms of progression.
And so these previous time concepts and
these different attempts to kind of
survey the structure of space time
reflect different cognitive models that
cognitive agents have proposed for time
and that communication actually takes
ontological primacy over all of these
ramified, potentially overlapping,
potentially non overlapping time concepts.
.
But they're downstream of agents
cognitive models, not vice versa.
I'm not sure it's how I interpreted what
Chris said about communication being an
ontological primary, though.
Ali: So if we take one instance of a
COVID-19 virus, a single kind of instance,
, right, it's got no memory and no
ability to plan.
Is there a local time for that virus
versus humanity observing how the virus
spreads across the globe?
And we have agents with memory and
planning.
Is there time relative to a single
photon?
My hunch is that there's a possibility
that we're simply inventing something
brand new and defining it brand new and
they draw in parallel back to all these
other times.
I understand the effort, but.
Ander: Is that.
Ali: A brand new time?
Is it some other kind of time?
I don't know.
Ander: Daniel.
Can I say words?
So I understand Alexis question, and I
think it's sort of related to, at least
morally speaking, to your concern about
different kinds of entropy, right?
And what I can say is that also they have
Glazebrook, Marciano and so on.
They have this recent paper on quantum
error correction, so I have yet to read
it and take a closer look.
But here they talk about space time,
right?
And my punch to address Alex's question
is that if you could sort of recover the
more familiar notions of time in a
correspondence principle sort of way by
taking some Newtonian limit or H bar goes
to zero or speed of Glycos infinity and
so on, that would be very satisfactory.
Sure, they may be doing a new thing, but
recovering old stuff in the new thing is
a good sanity check.
And so long as we can see that being
worked out, I think I'd be very happy.
Daniel: And just to the virus point, I
would argue that viruses, through their
physical engagement, they do have memory,
but they don't necessarily have the
awareness or metacognition on that memory,
, except as granted by intergenerational
evolutionary type pressure.
But they do have past events modifying
them within some set of possibilities.
So they're just being them and their
internal time.
There isn't a cognitive observer
necessarily.
Ander: In.
Daniel: Terms of like a narrative.
I I am watching the clock, but they do
change.
But it's certainly very provocative if
this is not.
Or we could also look to Kronos and
Cairos and about the relationship of time
and timeliness and agentic time.
And then at this point, are we stretching
just this one four letter word too far,
just like we brought up with information
entropy?
Can we think about these as kind of like
continents and then just if someone said,
I visited this continent, you know that
you need to specify a lot more, or what
granularity are these topics corby and
then anyone else raising their hands?
Ander: Yeah.
Corby: On this topic, for a Markov
blanket, you have a transition matrix.
My question is, how are you allowed to
increment that transition matrix to
calculate a future state?
What does that mean in terms of time?
Are you only allowed to increment it by
the lower bound time, which is h over Ln
and kBT.
Does that question make sense?
Daniel: I'll give a first pass on this.
We have discrete time and continuous time
models in Active Inference.
For a discrete time model where you have
the B transition matrix, then the choice
of Delta T is a modeler's decision.
And we talked about this a lot in live
stream 52 on accelerated optimization,
there's some Delta T that's like, going
to get you the most accelerated
optimization.
If you have too small of Delta T, then
you're either oversampling or you're
maybe even physically unrealistic like
you pointed to.
Or if you have some long Delta T, you're
also not making an informative simulation
in the discrete time case where you're
explicitly making time steps.
Contrast with the continuous time
generative model, where we're doing more
of a Taylor series expansion on the
generalized coordinates, at which point
Delta T is not required.
You're merely just taking an extended
approximation from a given snapshot, and
so Delta T doesn't even come into play.
Corby: Got it.
Okay, that makes sense.
I don't know how it ties into time, but
it helps clarify a little bit.
Daniel: Okay.
Anyone else can raise their hand or under
kind of maybe one more question or one
more topic from a paper?
Just what's one more puzzle piece that
you think gives us a first coat of paint
from questions submitted or from one of
these papers that you have up?
What's something that helps us connect
the dots a little bit?
Ander: I don't think I have a good answer.
.
Let me look at the questions again
regarding time.
I'll just reiterate what I said as I look
over these questions, which is that I
believe Chris will address it.
I don't know if you can see what I'm
sharing on the screen, but the paper,
whose title is Communication Protocols
blah blah blah from March of this year
does talk about spacetime.
It's a quantum error correction code, and
to me personally, it'd be nice to see if
that can be more familiar.
Notions of time, such as special
relativity can be recovered as limits in
correspondence principles.
Do you want me to say anything else?
Daniel: If anyone could even just
summarize what are these codes referring
to?
Or how are these codes one and the same
as communication protocols?
Or are they related to the blanket and
the heat that was being output as waste?
What will these codes allow us to do
better if we understood them more?
Ander: I don't know that I can answer
that right now.
I don't think they understand the
question.
Yeah, I just don't know.
Sorry.
Daniel: Terry.
And then anyone else raising their hands.
.
Ross: I'm not a physicist.
I don't understand maths at all.
But what attracted me to this idea of
physics as information processing is that
it feels like at a base level, whatever
the unknowable external state is, it
could be perceived as made up of
information.
You know, we we kind of think of
ourselves living in a particulate
universe, but at a base level there are
these and stop me if I'm just talking 14
year old nonsense here, but this notion
of quantum fields, they feel like
informational fields.
And that the concept of physics is purely
information that we then interpret as a
physical universe which we inhabit
because we can't see beyond our Markov
blanket.
I find this a really exciting idea.
Dean: That.
Ross: Whenever you start to think of the
surprisal as the variational free energy
between sort of your prior and your
posterior, if you start to think of that
variational free energy, not as energy
but as an information gap.
So that if you see the energy as actual
because energy, when you think of energy
in physics terms, it's kind of this
magical thing that allows work to happen.
.
But what is it?
We've got a term for it.
Is it jewels or whatever?
But what does it mean?
It has this magical property.
But if you think of it as information,
then it starts to make sense.
So variational free energy starts to be
seen as a difference in information
between your prior and your posterior.
So whenever you start to think about time,
, time is this conceptual metric that we
use almost because we have memory.
And I wonder if we are getting trapped in
this semantics.
And all I have is English because I don't
understand the maths really.
But you guys come in here and you do
understand the maths and then you convert
it into English, which I think I
understand.
And then I can think of it like a kid in
a sweetie shop or a physics class at 14
years of age.
I don't really know what I'm saying.
I don't know what I'm saying.
But at a fundamental level, everything
that we're talking about is I can
understand it as information.
And I'm excited to see how things develop.
.
What are your thoughts on this
craziness?
Daniel: So many great pieces in there.
Physics as information processing.
What is it that actually allows the steam
engine to run and the ball to move?
That kind of physics.
And then as the timeline laid out, also
occurring during a period of immense
technology and apparatus development and
digitization and all of this and
unconventional computing as well.
It's almost like this materialist dualism
that instead of with mind and body that
there was some kind of dualism between
the types of forces and energies and ways
of thinking about what made the steam
engine work and then what makes a
computer work.
And so you'd understand how the computer
could fall off a cliff, but then you
wouldn't necessarily be able to use that
exact kind of mechanics and physics and
dynamics to study like how the computer
operated.
But you could say it weighed eleven
pounds.
And so I think the provocation, which is
as you hinted towards first off, would be
awesome to have a natural language math
and graphical synthesis the triple play.
But also then to use a common approach to
understanding this and what wasn't
working or is not proposed to work, is
trying to fit information into that non
cognitive universe.
But rather if we take the cognitive
primacy of communication, then all of
these forces as inferred by the sensorium,
, which is all we're ever going to have,
totally the most valid first principles
constraint to make.
Maybe then we'll be able to have a lot
more synthesis about even how steam
engines work when we understand that we'
're bound in that inference by our
sensorium and all that comes along with
that and the variational free energy
bounding surprise on our generative model.
.
Dean.
Dean: I'm going to come at this from the
position of a 14 year old lens because I
don't think there's anything unique about
that.
I think on the most basic level, what I
took away from Chris's lecture was that
there's information processing of at
least two types.
One is figuring it out, as in figure five
or any of these other figures that are up
on the screen right now, or anything that
stabilizes the world around us.
I think examples have come up in this
conversation already of topology or
geometry.
There's a second type of information
processing which is outing the figure
type of information which is searching.
And I think Alexey used the expression
which time are we talking about?
So these two types of processes are quite
different.
If you do a comparative analysis of the
two, you have information practicing and
you have to have both of the processes to
really get a sense conceptually of what
it is that communication is really
talking about.
If you are information practicing your
wayfinding until you collapse to
something we might describe in a verb
tense as way found it's in the quantizing
of that invariant state, that vast ocean,
if you want to think of it.
Metaphorically out to all horizons on the
manifold into a variant or a nuanced or a
discretized or an orientation type of
state where all of a sudden things like
currents and temperature shifts and even
things that we've applied labels to, like
entropy and a transition matrix suddenly
appear out of the seeming nothingness or
the invariance.
So that's not the math, but that's kind
of stepping back and saying what is the
math trying to say?
I think it boils down to the comparative
analysis.
And then I'm hoping that in the coming
lectures, chris starts opening that up
and doing kind of the back and forth
between the two types of figuring it out
and outing the figures.
Because I think when both are part of the
conversation, that's when we start to get
a sense of what's really going on.
Daniel: Thank you.
In this sort of closing sessions,
especially if anyone hasn't added
anything, please feel free to give any
last reflections or questions arising.
So first, as many people as would like
can reflect that way.
And then after every hand has been
addressed, then ander if you could just
give us a kind of look ahead.
So Avel first, then Anyone else with just
where does this discussion take us and
where do you want to continue to learn
more about Avel?
Avel: So, two things.
First, if I walk out of here without
understanding what is coconut, I will be
disappointed.
And I don't actually expect it to happen
in like 12 hours.
That seems like it's something.
But more seriously, I can agree with that
difficulty that there is a unity between
physical structure and communication
protocols and that communication
protocols are quantum reference frame,
kind of individuate physical states,
individuate meaningful measurement
outcomes that are ray file as physical
possibilities.
But the question is then where do
communication protocols, quantum
merchants frame come from?
Like, what are the physical determinants
that bring about those things?
And that seems like a question that could
be addressed at the conceptual level of
this course.
And I would like I saw the live stream 17,
, so that did not help.
Anyway, I would like to have more grip
into that if we can address it in the
foreign courses.
Ander: Thank you.
Daniel: Thank you.
Anyone else?
Especially if they haven't added anything
yet, want to give kind of a closing
thought?
Yeah, there's a lot to learn and Chris
brings up a lot in his lecture, even
though we've only had one.
It's one of the denser hours of epistemic
resourcing that I've seen.
And there's also all of these accessory
and cutting edge works that under showing.
.
So I'm really looking forward to how we
can continue to curate and improve the
questions that we have so that the
uncertainties in our generative model
that we have, how would this be useful?
What does this mean?
Why is this variable this way?
What is the implication for that?
Those are all the great questions and let'
's just get them inscribed on our
classical documents so that we can have
other quantum cognitive agents reduce
their uncertainty by looking at the
responses.
So with that under, if you could just
look ahead to lecture two and just point
towards where we're going to be going.
Ander: Yes, lecture two will, I think
from what I hear from Chris, is going to
start to address these basic ontological
aspects of the quantum measurement.
So the two sources to look at would be
two papers, mainly this one, Physical
Meaning of Holographic Principle.
This one's, by far the most pedagogical
one.
So if I had to suggest that books look at
one, it would be this one.
It's very easy to read, I think, but
maybe for a bit more detail there's the
slightly older one and they talk at
length about Cocoa and the headgrounds
here, Free Energy Principle for Generic
Content Systems.
So I think that's what's going to come in
these two lectures.
Basically, the main ideas behind these
two papers and yeah, that's all I have to
say.
Daniel: All right, well, thank you for
all who joined this first discussion.
Hope that it was fun for you and for the
audience.
And check out the course site for the
readings to get ahead of the second
lecture.
We'll all watch the second lecture and
come back in about a month for the second
discussion.
Everyone's welcome to join, and the
website has the registration information.
.
And so now that we've seen a little bit
of one way, it can be we may do something
similar or we may do something different
for the second discussion.
So thanks again, everybody.
See you later.
Ander: Bye.